let's keep talking about impeachment a
little bit Democrats are starting to
speak out against Nancy Pelosi and to
sort of break with her on the issue of
starting impeachment proceedings against
Donald Trump and it's getting really
interesting and it could actually get
very damaging for Democrats and I'll
tell you about that and and how that
would work in a few minutes if you
haven't been following Nancy Pelosi has
been very reticent to take impeachment
hearings sort of seriously even saying a
couple of times that Democrats shouldn't
go down that path because it divides the
country that Trump is quote not worth it
in terms of even bothering to impeach
him and the question more and more is
that it's not a matter of Trump being
worth it for me it's a question of
whether the country is worth it in terms
of what Trump has done and what the
correct consequences would be for that
so in any case as I told you yesterday
talk a bit of impeachment among high
profile Democrats is growing pretty
quickly Elizabeth Warren and Kamala
Harris have both said that they support
starting the impeachment process against
Donald Trump there are more and more
prominent Democrats who have been saying
in interviews that Donald Trump has
certainly committed impeachable offenses
and now the disagreement between these
prominent Democrats and Nancy Pelosi
has gone beyond what it was before which
was really I don't want to insult
anybody but more obscure or less well
known Democrats you had you know Al
Green tried to actually start
impeachment proceedings on the floor of
the house you've got Elizabeth Warren
now you've got Elijah Cummings talking
about if not now when how and how and
when will trump face consequences Jerry
Nadler and Adam Schiff hinting more and
more at impeachment would at least be
justified if not the next thing that we
want to do impeachment would be really
difficult to actually see through to the
removal of the President of the United
States it's a long process but there are
two ways that this impeachment thing
could go without the successful removal
of Trump and Democrats need to make sure
they're not on the wrong side of it okay
so for the the important discussion here
for me is
can trunk be removed via impeachment
right now the answer is very clearly no
you need Republicans to do that
Republicans are completely unwilling 30%
of the country is an immutable
unchangeable base for Donald Trump I
call him the shoot someone on Fifth
Avenue crowd so there are really
political considerations here and
Democrats could be on one side or they
could end up on the other one path for
Democrats is Democrats just keep arguing
and being divided about this issue of
impeachment and they hurt themselves by
getting into very public disagreements
about impeachment and it ends up hurting
them in 2020 that's bad
okay Democrats need to avoid that the
other path is that Democrats say at a
minimum we're gonna have a floor debate
about impeachment okay we want to start
floor debate about whether impeachment
proceedings should start against the
President of the United States they are
united on the debate and the content of
the debates becomes newsworthy and they
make impeachment a political problem for
Trump in the campaign okay if you ask me
which I prefer it's obvious which is
better Democrats arguing about
impeachment and hurting themselves or
Democrats uniting and saying the
evidence justifies a floor debate about
impeachment let's at least start that
and see if the way that it is picked up
in media and the way that Donald Trump
reacts hurts Trump makes this a burden
for Trump for the 2020 election when
Bill Clinton lied about oral sex
republicans were united you had every
sort of Ashkelon
with some very minor holdouts saying
this is the right thing this is what
we've got to do here's why it's
justified they didn't succeed obviously
in removing Bill Clinton but they not
only had the debate and were united they
actually filed articles of impeachment
against Bill Clinton we now have a
president whose egregious behavior
exceeds Bill Clinton lying about oral
sex by leaps and bounds and Democrats
have the opportunity
you use this to help them in defeating
Trump in 2020 or they have the
opportunity of hurting themselves just
by arguing endlessly and publicly about
whether there should be any consequences
or even potential consequences for what
Donald Trump has done as exposed by the
Moller report it's a great way to lose
yourself another election and I hope
that Democrats get it together and don't
go in that direction and go in the
direction of being United and saying
there have to be consequences and at
minimum we need a very public debate
about whether those consequences should
include the filing of articles of
impeachment not a strategy to remove
Trump but important to be united and to
not let this hurt the movement to remove
him in 2020 let me know what you think
we're gonna put a poll related to this
on the show's Instagram page which is
david pakman show on instagram and while
you're there follow me on instagram as
well i'm david pakman i did post this
picture from a passover seder over the
weekend for which i am getting a lot a
lot of hate which i discussed yesterday
on the bonus show you can check out that
picture if you follow me on instagram at
david pakman quick break
very interesting segment coming up next
if you love learning new things you
probably want to check this out the
david pakman show today is sponsored by
Skillshare and we're giving you two
entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learn
something that's totally new to you
something you want to get better at
something you already love or you can
get ahead in your career by learning new
skills that will help you at your job
I've gotten a ton out of it Pat has
taken some courses that he's found
really valuable and I think you'll love
it to get started for free by clicking
the link under this video